[Musik]
Dieser Podcast wird Ihnen von der LMU
München präsentiert. Was sind Personen und wie
existieren sie? Das Thema dieses Kolloquiums
Was sind Personen und wie existieren sie
?
nur für natürlich existierende
einzelne Menschen, aber auch für nicht
natürliche Wesen wie juristische
Personen, dramatis personae und die
Person Gottes, ohne diese Verwendungen zu berücksichtigen, ist
es auf keinen Achsen zu sitzen
die
organisatoren nennen den satz über die
personen dort verwenden wir den begriff person nicht
nur für natürlich existierende natürlich natürliche
personen wie du und ich sondern auch nicht
natürliche wesen wie juristische personen
dramatis personae und die person gottes
ohne diese verwendungen des
wortes person als zu berücksichtigen  Äquivokationen stellt sich
die Frage, was Personen wirklich sind
und wie sie existieren, wenn sie nicht
nur als Naturwesen gedacht, sondern
auch nicht expl
Nun, das haben die Organisatoren als nicht natürliche Wesenheiten
gesagt. Lassen Sie uns sagen, diese Formulierung
ist meiner Ansicht nach faszinierend. Was
Personen wirklich sind, sind menschliche Personen, die
sich ohne menschliches Eingreifen entwickelt haben, aber
die Organisatoren sagen, dass es keine
Zweideutigkeit gibt, aber wie die Organisatoren sagen,
gibt es keine  Zweideutigkeit bei der Bezeichnung
dramatis personae usw. Personen Der Grund dafür,
dass es in meinem Du keine Zweideutigkeit
gibt, ist, dass die Anwendung des Begriffs
Person für Entitäten, die sich nicht natürlich entwickelt haben,
der Fall dessen ist, was
Aristoteles Protion Hahnemann Anonyme in den
Kategorien Pro Shinja Nanami genannt hat, ist das
Phänomen  von homonymen, die ihre
bedeutung durch bezug auf ein zentrales
paradigma erhalten, wenn aristoteles das beispiel
von gesund benutzte das wort gesund können wir
von gesunder nahrung, gesundem teint und
gesundem urin sprechen, aber um diese worte zu verstehen
, müssen wir verstehen, wo
gesunder organismus aristoteles die zentrale
bedeutung nahm  von gesund, um
von seiner Anwendung auf Organismen zu kommen, wenn yo
Sie verstehen nicht, was ein gesunder
Organismus ist Sie werden nicht verstehen, was
gesunde Nahrung ist oder gesund eine gesunde
Haut gesunde Nahrung ist
Nahrung, die der Gesundheit eines Organismus förderlich ist eine
gesunde Haut oder Haut, die
auf einen gesunden Organismus hindeuten so menschlich
finde ich den Begriff  menschliche Person ist
wie der Begriff gesund, wenn Sie nicht wissen,
was eine menschliche Person ist, werden Sie nicht wissen
, was dramatis personae sind
dramatis personae
sind Charaktere, die von natürlichen Menschen gespielt werden
Rechte von Personen, also gibt es in beiden
Fällen einen sprachlichen Unterschied, eine
Asymmetrie zwischen der Verankerung oder
unabhängigen Verwendung eines Begriffs, der manchmal
als zentrale Bedeutung bezeichnet wird, wie ein gesunder
Organismus, eine gesunde Person, und der gebundenen
oder abhängigen Verwendung von Begriffen wie
gesunde Ernährung, juristische Person, aber
es gibt  keine Zweideutigkeit, sie erhalten nur
ihre Bedeutung, einige einige Verwendungen des
Begriffs Person erhalten ihre Bedeutung  Durch
Bezugnahme auf Dinge wie
uns
, hängt die Bedeutung des Begriffs „gesund“ in seiner gebundenen oder abhängigen Verwendung
von seiner Bedeutung in der verankernden
oder unabhängigen Verwendung ab, ebenso hängt die Bedeutung
von Person in seiner gebundenen oder in oder
abhängigen Verwendung von seiner Bedeutung ab  in
der Verankerung, genauso wie es einen großen
Unterschied zwischen der Verwendung, in der
Lebensmittel gesund sind, und der Art und Weise, wie ich meine, Entschuldigung, dem
Unterschied zwischen der Art und Weise, in der
Obst gesund ist, und der Art und Weise, in der
Organismen gesund sind, gibt, also gibt es einen großen
Unterschied zwischen der  So wie
juristische Personen Personen sind und
wie wir Personen sind, gäbe es
keine gesunde Ernährung, wenn es keine
Organismen gäbe, und es gäbe keine
juristischen Personen, wenn es keine natürlichen Personen gäbe, unter denen
wir uns die anderen Personen vorstellen, unter denen
wir sie als Personen bezeichnen könnten
Konvention in Bezug auf natürliche
Personen wie uns selbst das eine Beispiel
, das nicht genau in dieses Schema passt, tut
mir leid, aber das tut es nicht, ist
Gott anders als wir f  kleine Personen, die
zu verschiedenen Zeiten entstanden sind Gott, wenn
er existiert, entsteht überhaupt nicht,
er ist ewig Die Verwendung von Person,
um sich auf Gott zu beziehen, stammt von dem Wort zu
verwenden, um sich auf die Masken zu beziehen, die
sogar in alten griechischen und lateinischen Ritualen getragen wurden
Daher verwenden wir heute den Begriff Person Gottes, um
anzuzeigen, dass einige von Gottes
Eigenschaften analog zu unseren sind
Intellekt, der Linguist möchte nun
zwischen sprachlichen und
sprachlichen gerechten Unterschieden und einem
ontologischen Unterschied unterscheiden. Sprachlich
gesprochen hängt unser Gebrauch von Person, um sich auf Gott zu beziehen,
von unserem Gebrauch von Person ab,
um uns auf natürliche menschliche Personen zu beziehen
Unter der Annahme, dass Gott
existiert, ist es, ontologisch gesehen, wirklich eine Person
zu sein, im Gegensatz zu seiner bloßen Benennung als
Person ist ontologi  cal II vor uns
und allem anderen, aber ich vermute, dass
das Wort Person in Person Gottes
nur die Vermutung von Intellekt und
Willen zum einfachen Wort Gott hinzufügt, wo die
Wörter Intellekt und Wille in
der Verwendung dieser Begriffe verankert sind, auf die sie sich beziehen
Eigenschaften menschlicher Personen, so dass wir
die Person in Person Gottes als einen
weiteren Fallansatz in huh nominee behandeln können, wo Gott
analog zu uns eine Person ist, das ist nur
ein sprachlicher Punkt, es ist kein
ontologischer Punkt, ob dies alles
richtig ist, um die Titelfrage zu beantworten  Was
sind Personen und wie existieren sie? Die
einzigen Fragen, die wir untersuchen müssen,
betrafen die Natur
natürlicher Personen wie wir selbst. Wir
brauchen keine gesonderte Untersuchung der
anderen Art von Einheiten, die wir
per Konvention oder im Falle von Personen als Personen bezeichnen
Gottpersonen brauchen wir analog dazu
nicht gesondert zu untersuchen,
da sie durch ihre
Beziehung zu natürlichen Personen wie uns charakterisiert sind, also
was sind Personen und wie existieren sie
Ich beginne mit der zweiten Hälfte dieser
Frage. Wir mögen uns
mit oder ohne göttliche Hilfe natürlich entwickelt haben, aber ich glaube nicht
, dass wir daran ablesen können, was wir
am grundlegendsten sind, wie wir hierher gekommen sind.
Mein Interesse ist hier das Ontologische, das ist
mein Interesse  konzentriert sich auf die Frage nach dem, was
wirklich existiert, Fragen, was sein
muss, muss in einer Bestandsaufnahme des
wirklich Realen erwähnt werden, nicht reduzierbar, sondern
in sich selbst echt real,
was für Wesen wir im Grunde sind
Einflussreiche Ansichten
Bis vor kurzem war die vorherrschende Antwort auf
die Frage,
was eine Person ist, dass wir
Menschen Personen immaterielle Seelen haben oder sind.
Ich nenne diese Ansicht einen Materialismus,
aber die moderne Synthese in der Biologie
macht deutlich, dass wir
mit dem Rest zusammenhängen  des Tierreichs wird also ein
Materialismus durch die Ansicht herausgefordert,
dass wir nur Tiere sind, nur Primaten,
eine Art von Primaten, unter anderem,
Tierismus, diese Ansicht wird glaube ich genannt  Ich denke,
dass diese beiden Sichtweisen in Bezug auf Materialismus
und
Animalismus für jeden Materialismus, der entweder
eine immaterielle Seele ist oder hat, unangemessen sind, aber wie
Kritiker wie die von Descartes
schnell betonten, gibt es keinen Hinweis darauf,
wie immaterielle Seelen miteinander verbunden werden können  zu
organischen Körpern greift der Materialismus zu
kurz, indem er nicht zeigt, wie wir sind, sondern
indem er nicht zeigt, wie wir mit unseren angeblichen
Seelen mit dem Tierreich verwandt sind
Animalismus zwischen uns und
den anderen Primaten, aber wenn ich im
Wesentlichen dieses Tier bin, das hier steht,
dann könnte ich ohne diesen organischen Körper nicht existieren,
insbesondere könnte ich
den Ersatz meines organischen Körpers
dieses Tiers durch einen uns allen bekannten nicht-organischen Körper
nicht überleben  atemberaubende Innovationen
in der Biotechnologie, nicht nur künstliche
Hüften, ordentliche Knie und Herzen und Lebern,
sondern auch Cokely Cochlea-Implantate und
Brain Machine Int  Oberflächen, die es
völlig gelähmten Menschen ermöglichen,
Roboterglieder mit ihren Gedanken zu bedienen, wenn
Sie kein Video davon
gesehen haben, lohnt es sich, es sich anzusehen, wirklich
bemerkenswert
das verband ihr Gehirn mit einem biotischen Arm,
so dass ihr biotischer Arm, wenn sie bestimmte Gedanken
dachte, die Hand ausstreckte, um ein
Glas Wasser aufzuheben, und sie davon trank
, immer noch vollständig in all
ihren natürlichen Teilen gelähmt, okay,
wir sind atemberaubende, atemberaubende Innovationen
Biologie kann ein Mensch überleben
Ersatz organischer Körperteile durch viele Arten von
immer raffinierteren künstlichen
Geräten Irgendwann wird der computergestützte
Ersatz von Teilen eines
Tieres so umfassend und so integriert sein, dass
die resultierende Entität kein Organismus mehr sein
wird, aber immer noch ein
Person, ich weiß nicht einmal über diese
Person, die ich in dem Video gesehen habe, ob sie
künstliche Hüften künstliche kn gesagt hätte  Es gibt ein
künstliches Herz, alle
Organe, die wir kennen, die transplantiert werden können,
plus ein künstliches Etwas in ihrem
Gehirn. Ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob wir sagen würden,
dass ihr Körper ein tierischer Körper war, der
bereits ausreichen könnte, um
nein zu sagen  nicht mehr, es ist kein tierischer
Körper, denke ich, aber ich werde
diesen Punkt nicht weiter hervorheben. Irgendwann ist es okay, es ist so,
irgendwann denke ich, dass es das Ende sein
wird, dass nicht-organischer Ersatz
ausreichen wird, damit wir den Körper nicht mehr anrufen
werden  Bei einer Person ist es immer ein Tier oder ein
organischer Körper, es wird kein Organismus sein,
weil Organismen im Wesentlichen auf
Kohlenstoff basieren und diese künstlichen
Körper größtenteils oder vollständig nicht organisch oder
daher nicht auf Kohlenstoff basierend sind,
je nach Animalismus, für den Ihr organischer
Körper wesentlich ist  Sie also, wenn es möglich ist,
dass Sie ohne Ihren organischen Körper überleben können,
dann ist Animalismus falsch.
Animalismus ist nicht nur den Veränderungen
gewachsen, die durch die Biotechnologie gehen
Mysterium noch
Animalismus, der die besonderen Organkörper nimmt,
die wir jetzt
für unser Überleben brauchen, ist der
Natur des Menschen angemessen, oder wie ich menschliche Personen sagen werde,
ich verwende diese Begriffe
synonym Mensch eine menschliche Person,
wir brauchen einen anderen Ansatz als den
Materialismus  und Animalismus, und ich glaube
, ich habe eine
Ansicht, die ich
Konstitutionalismus nenne, die sowohl die Probleme des Tiers als auch des
Animalismus umgeht, und im Materialismus
gemäß dem
Konstitutionalismus beginnt die Beziehung zwischen Menschen und Menschen, die
von Tieren oder Organismen gebildet, aber nicht mit ihnen identisch sind
der
Konstitution ist eine Beziehung der Einheit, aber
keine strenge Identität, wenn ein Achtel, wenn
ein Tier zur Zeit T eine Person darstellt,
es eine einzelne Entität T bei einer Person gibt, die zur Zeit
t von einem Tier gebildet wird, hinter der
Idee der Konstitution eine aristotelische
Annahme für jedes X wir ist  Ich kann fragen, was
X am grundlegendsten ist. Meine
Antwort lautet: X ist die primäre Art, das ist das, was X am
grundlegendsten ist  mental ist alles, was existiert,
von genau einer primären Art ist ein
Pferd ein Kohl ein Reisepass eine Sache eine
primäre Art ist wesentlich für die Sache, die
es bestimmt die Dinge Beständigkeit
bedingt die Bedingungen, unter denen es
überlebt oder nicht wenn etwas von
einer primären Art  entsteht unter bestimmten
Umständen etwas von einer anderen
primären Art, wenn
etwa zwei Wasserstoffatome und ein
Sauerstoffatom unter bestimmten Umständen der
chemischen Bindung ein neues Ding sind, ein
Wassermolekül entsteht oder wenn ein
Stück Papier einer bestimmten Sorte unter
bestimmten Umständen entsteht  Umstände es gibt rechtliche
Umstände alle möglichen Umstände
nicht nur körperliche, sondern wenn ein Canapé ein
bestimmtes Stück Papier ein Stück
Papier einer bestimmten Art unter
Umständen eine neue
Sache ist entsteht ein US-Dollar-
Schein ähnlich wie wenn ein menschlicher
Organismus darin ist  unter bestimmten Umständen eine
neue Entität eine Person entsteht
die Umstände, unter denen ein menschlicher
Organismus zu Widerständen kommt  Eine Person zu benennen oder
die Entwicklung von Bewusstsein und
Intentionalität, die eine Person ist, entsteht,
wenn ein menschlicher Organismus oder
Fötus die Fähigkeit entwickelt, das zu unterstützen,
was ich eine rudimentäre Perspektive der ersten Person nenne.
Menschen und Tiere sind
grundlegend verschiedene Arten, Tiere
sind im Wesentlichen organische Personen  sind im
Wesentlichen Träger dessen, was ich
Perspektiven der ersten Person
nenne, jeder, der eine Person darstellen kann oder nicht,
muss in der Lage sein, eine
Perspektive
der ersten Person zu unterstützen  sind mit
dem Tierreich verwandt Personen sind im
Wesentlichen verkörpert und wir beginnen
unsere Existenz durch Organismen konstituiert, im Gegensatz zum
Animalismus, der eine Person nur als einen weiteren Primaten betrachtet
P  ositiert durch Animalismus, sondern eher
die zeitgebundene und kontingente Beziehung
der Verfassung.
Was uns jedoch von allen anderen Wesen unterscheidet,
ist, dass wir von einer Art sind, die das entwickelt,
was ich robuste Ich-Perspektiven nenne,
meiner Ansicht nach ist eine Ich-
Perspektive eine  Zweistufige
Dispositionseigenschaft Ich-Perspektiven haben
rudimentäre und robuste Stadien Ganz
grob gesagt entspricht die Unterscheidung zwischen den
rudimentären und robusten Stadien
dem Unterschied zwischen
Bewusstsein und Selbstbewusstsein,
bevor ich die beiden Stadien der
Ich-Perspektive erläutern möchte
Einige der Merkmale, die uns
Menschen nicht vom Rest der
Natur unterscheiden. Zuerst mögen wir den Rest des
Tierreichs, das sich durch natürliche
Selektion entwickelt hat,
vielleicht durch gelenkte Selektion, wie Planica
darauf besteht, oder vielleicht hat die ungelenkte Evolution
es getan, und viele Biologen bestehen darauf, dass
es dauern würde  Wir sind zu weit weg, um
hier darüber zu streiten, ob der Glaube an Gott
mit der natürlichen Auserwählung vereinbar ist  ion, also
bleibe ich in dieser Angelegenheit neutral, der
jetzige Punkt ist, dass wir
keinen besonderen Anfang postulieren müssen, um unsere
Existenz
zu erklären  Am
Anfang unserer Existenz haben sowohl Menschen
als auch nichtmenschliche Tiere die gleichen
Arten von Organen, die aus den gleichen
Arten von kohlenstoffbasierten Zellen bestehen. Es wurde
geschätzt, dass wir 98,6 % unseres
genetischen Materials mit Schimpansen teilen,
was vieles erklären könnte
Drittens mögen wir andere Arten
soziale Wesen Es
gibt empirische Unterstützung für den sozialen
Charakter von Primaten, einschließlich uns, die wir
beginnen, die von Primaten gebildet werden. Der
Psychologe Michael Tomasello führte
kognitive Tests mit zweijährigen
Menschen und erwachsenen Orang-Utans
und Schimpansen durch und fand dies heraus  Die einzigen
Stellen, an denen die Menschen
die nichtmenschlichen Primaten übertrafen, waren
Tests, bei denen soziale Fähigkeiten, soziales
Lernen, Kommunikation und das Lesen der
Absichten anderer gemessen wurden  ers viertens mögen wir
andere Primaten sind Problemlöser
es gibt umfangreiche Literatur alle
lösen keine Probleme zum Beispiel Scientific
American berichtete über Arbeiten, die zeigten,
dass Bonobos und Orang-Utans nicht
nur Werkzeuge verwenden können, um einen Fruchtgenuss aus
einem mechanischen Apparat zu bekommen, sondern auch
vorausplanen können  Ich nehme an, dass die
Problemlösungsfähigkeit nichtmenschlicher Tiere
darauf hinweist, dass nichtmenschliche
Tiere Bewusstsein und Intentionalität haben,
und meiner Ansicht nach haben Wesen mit
Bewusstsein und Intentionalität
die erste Stufe der Roba der
Ich-Perspektive, was ich die
rudimentäre erste nenne  Personenperspektive Eine
Entität mit einer rudimentären Ich-
Perspektive kann Dinge in der Umgebung wahrnehmen und mit ihnen interagieren,
außerdem
nehme ich menschliche Säuglinge wie die meisten Menschen
als Personen mit rudimentären
Ich-Perspektiven, so wie
viele nichtmenschliche Tiere
rudimentäre haben  Ich-Perspektive,
was dann Menschen von
Tieren unterscheidet, weil es ist  wichtig für mich,
dass wir einzigartig sind, wie können menschliche
Säuglinge Personen sein, Schimpansen jedoch keine
Personen
trotz ihrer Ähnlichkeit der DNA und der
Tatsache, dass beide Arten von Wesen, menschliche
Säuglinge und Schimpansen, rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektiven haben, was ist der
Unterschied zwischen ihnen, weil ich  Denken Sie,
dass ein menschliches Kind ohne
die Friedhofs-Ich-
Perspektive eine Person ist, aber ein Schimpanse nicht. Ich
werde hier eine vorläufige Antwort geben und
am Ende des Vortrags ausführlicher antworten. Der
Konstitutionalismus bietet zwei Arten von
Antworten  Ich bin hauptsächlich von
technischem Interesse und
eines meiner Ziele und Philosophie ist es, die
Philosophie der analytischen Philosophie,
wie ich sie mache, relevanter für das Leben der Menschen zu machen,
nur diese technischen Probleme,
über die die Leute die ganze Zeit reden, die ich wirklich
bringen möchte  bodenständig gut
sowieso das versuche ich zu tun, aber
die erste Antwort ist eine technische Antwort.
Die technische Antwort ist, dass
ich nur die Perspektive der ersten Person habe  es im
Wesentlichen und Tiere, die
Ich-Perspektiven haben, haben sie nur
bedingt, dass das Tier, von dem ein Schimpanse sagt
, als Fötus existiert, bevor es eine
rudimentäre Ich-Perspektive entwickelt, und
daher keine rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektive hat, im Wesentlichen existiert die
Person nicht  nicht entstehen,
bis sie von einem
Organismus konstituiert werden, der eine rudimentäre
Perspektive der ersten Person unterstützen kann, die die
Person dann im Wesentlichen hat. Das ist ein
Grund zu sagen, dass eine Person nicht
mit einem Tier identisch ist, weil eine Person
als Person entsteht a
Person ist nicht auf etwas anderes reduzierbar.
Ich werde diese erste
Antwort auf die Frage, was uns
besonders, aber anders als
Tiere macht, übergehen, weil ich denke,
dass die zweite Antwort mehr aufschlussreich
über die Art von Dingen ist, die wir
grundsätzlich sind  sind die ersten nicht
falsch, denke ich, aber es ist technisch
und viele Leute würden sagen, wen interessiert das, ich
würde das natürlich nicht sagen  e, weil Sie
wissen, dass ich in diesem Fach promoviert habe, die
zweite Antwort auf die Frage, was
der Unterschied zwischen menschlichen Säuglingen und
Schimpansen ist, aufgrund dessen der
Säugling, aber nicht der Schimpanse als
Person, diese menschlichen Säuglinge, aber
keine Schimpansen sind  dass eine primäre
Art, die typischerweise das entwickelt, was ich eine robuste Ich-Perspektive nenne,
menschliche Säuglinge wie Schimpansen eine
rudimentäre Ich-Perspektive haben, aber im
Gegensatz zu Schimpansen menschliche Säuglinge
auch eine Fähigkeit zweiter Ordnung haben,
eine robuste Ich-Perspektive zu
entwickeln, elip ein robustes Stadium entwickeln  der
Ich-Perspektive, wenn sie
eine natürliche Sprache beherrschen und ein Selbstkonzept erwerben,
bei dem eine Fähigkeit zweiter Ordnung eine
Fähigkeit ist, eine Fähigkeit zu entwickeln.
Schauen wir uns nun die
rudimentären und robusten Stadien der
Ich-Perspektive genauer an,
beginnend mit  Das rudimentäre Stadium
hier sind drei wichtige Merkmale einer
rudimentären Ich-Perspektive,
ob es sich um einen Schimpansen handelt  oder ein
Säugling oder du und ich, die sie auch haben
- erstens ist es eine Perspektive eine
Perspektive ist kein Objekt es ist nichts,
was man einnimmt, um es zu haben eine
Perspektive ist dazu bereit,
die Welt aus einem bestimmten
Blickwinkel wahrzunehmen zweitens  Selbst die
rudimentäre Ich-Perspektive ist
zuerst persönlich, sie bezieht sich nicht explizit
auf ihren Träger zuerst persönlich oder
anderweitig, sondern liefert den Standardort
eines bewussten Subjekts die
Quelle ihres Wahrnehmungsfelds den
Ort, von dem aus das Subjekt
die Umgebung wahrnimmt, mit der es
interagiert  3 Eine rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektive erfordert
keine sprachlichen oder konzeptionellen
Fähigkeiten, so dass Entitäten, denen Konzepte fehlen,
menschliche Säuglinge und nichtmenschliche Tiere,
beide rudimentäre Ich-Perspektiven genießen können.
Ich sollte sagen, dass ich denke,
dass Konzepte an die natürliche Sprache gebunden sind,
wenn es welche gäbe  keine natürlichen
Sprachen, es gäbe keine Konzepte,
da dies das Ende meines Eintauchens in die
Aggression ist, wie ich dort erwähnt habe  sind zwei
Bedingungen für eine Entität, um ein
rudimentäres
Bewusstsein aus der Ich-Perspektive und Intentionalität zu haben. Eine
Entität hat nur dann Bewusstsein, wenn sie
in der Lage ist, sich etwas bewusst zu sein.
Der Begriff Perspektive ist angemessen,
da alles Bewusstsein und
Bewusstsein perspektivisch ist, was die Intentionalität
zum Bewusstsein hinzufügt, ist minimal  Agentur
zielgerichtetes Verhalten, es
gibt eine Menge empirischer
Arbeit an neugeborenen Babys, und selbst wenn sie
nur ein paar Minuten alt sind, haben sie keine
Probleme, die Brüste ihrer Mutter zu finden
, das ist ein absichtliches Verhalten,
sie haben keine Probleme, jemanden zu imitieren, an dem
wir festhalten  Zunge raus
Zungenvorsprung Das ist der Grund, dass
das Kind seine Zunge herausstreckt 42
Minuten Alles, was sie tun, ist das
Alison Gopnik Unterstützung einer Entität mit
nur einer rudimentären Ich-
Perspektive, die mentale Zustände hat, aber kein
Selbstkonzept oder Selbstverständnis der
Entität einfach  steht am Ursprung
jenes Teils der Wirklichkeit, der es kann
wahrnehmen und mit all seinen
Wahrnehmungen interagieren mentale Zustände sind
standardmäßig zuallererst persönlich, aber der Träger
dieser mentalen Zustände betrachtet sie
nicht als zuerst persönlich, eine Entität mit einer
rudimentären Ich-Perspektive
kratzt nur dort, wo es juckt, und trägt nicht
etwas anderes oder das andere
Das Markenzeichen einer rudimentären
Ich-Perspektive ist die Fähigkeit
, die Welt wahrzunehmen und absichtlich
darauf zu reagieren, ohne
ein Ich-Konzept von sich selbst zu haben, oder ein
Selbstkonzept, das sich nun der robusten
Ich-Perspektive zuwendet, die die
erste Stufe ist  als eine rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektive, die wir
mit einigen
nicht-menschlichen Tieren teilen, nicht nur mit Primaten, wir
teilen sie mit vielen Säugetieren, vielleicht
alles Männchen,
Schweine, Kühe, alle eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive, für den Moment, den wir haben
Übergang zur zweiten Stufe Eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive ist eine konzeptionelle
Fähigkeit, die erworben wird, wenn ein Kleinkind eine
natürliche Sprache lernt, es ist die Fähigkeit
Sich selbst als sich selbst in der ersten
Person zu sehen, ist die Fähigkeit, nicht nur zu
denken, dass ich hungrig bin oder Baby als hungrig oder
Essen, sondern auch zu denken, dass ich wünschte, ich wäre
nicht hungrig, wo das zweite
Vorkommen von ich und ich wünsche, dass ich  Wenn ich
wünschte, ich wäre nicht hungrig, sind Signale, die
Sie an sich selbst denken, und die
erste Person, an die Sie auf die erste
persönliche Art und Weise gedacht haben, Teil des Inhalts
Ihres Gedankens,
obwohl Personen mit höheren
nichtmenschlichen Tieren geteilt werden  rudimentäre
Perspektiven aus der ersten Person Nur Menschen
entwickeln jemals robuste
Perspektiven aus der ersten Person, daher der zweite wichtige
Unterschied zwischen menschlichen Säuglingen und
Schimpansen
Lassen Sie mich die robuste
Ich-Perspektive mit ein wenig
Fantasie veranschaulichen, die ich zuvor verwendet habe, aber ich
mag es, nehme an, dass Jane Jones ist  Eine
milliardenschwere Hedgefonds-Managerin, die
natürlich glaubt, dass sie
selbst reich ist. Sie hat eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive, wenn sie glaubt,
dass sie selbst reich ist, aber eines Tages wird
sie entführt, auf den Kopf geschlagen
und bewusstlos am Straßenrand liegen gelassen
Im ländlichen Vermont, wenn sie sich erholt,
kann sie sich nicht an ihr früheres Leben erinnern, aber ihre
Ich-Perspektive ist so robust wie
immer, dass sie sich selbst als sie selbst begreifen kann
und sich fragt, ob sie jemals ihr Gedächtnis wiedererlangen wird, dass
sie jemals wieder wissen wird, wer
sie ist  verdient seinen Lebensunterhalt mit
einem Schaf auf einer Schaffarm in Vermont und
liest regelmäßig die Zeitung von in der
Zeitung über einen Jay Jones, den
verschollenen Hedgefonds-Manager, der tatsächlich
die Person ist, die über diese Person liest, ohne zu
wissen, dass es sich um dieselbe Person handelt, zu der
Jones kommt  glauben, dass Jones,
der Hedgefonds-Manager, wohlhabend ist, aber
dass sie selbst nicht auf einer Schaffarm arbeitet
, dann hat unsere Schaffarm Jones
die Vermont-Lotterie gewonnen, während sie gleichzeitig
gelesen hat  In der Zeitung steht, dass
der Hedgefonds, den Jones
früher führte, aufgrund von Missmanagement zusammengebrochen ist und dass
Jones jetzt arm ist und immer noch nicht glaubt, dass
sie selbst Jones ist. Jones glaubt, dass
sie selbst reich ist, sagte, sie habe im
Lotto gewonnen, glaubt Jones aber nicht
dessen Vermögen verloren gegangen ist,
so glaubt Jones nach ihrer Entführung
, dass Jones reich ist, aber nicht,
dass sie selbst reich ist, und nachdem
er die Lotterie gewonnen und sie vom
Untergang der Hedgefonds gelesen hat, glaubt Jones,
dass sie selbst reich ist, aber nicht, dass
Jones reich ist  Daher ist
Jones 'Überzeugung, dass Jones reich ist,
nicht gleichbedeutend mit Jones 'Überzeugung, dass
sie selbst reich ist, da beide
Überzeugungen wahr sein können, wenn die andere
falsch ist. Die robuste Ich-
Perspektive ist die Fähigkeit zu
begreifen, diese Unterscheidung zu treffen, um sich
selbst als sie selbst zu begreifen  in der ersten Person
und damit zu unterscheiden zwischen dem Denken
an jemanden, der es zufälligerweise selbst ist,
und dem Denken an sich selbst  Wie Sie selbst in
der ersten Person, geht es hier darum, dass Jones,
ob sie es weiß oder nicht
, sich genauso sicher mit Jones auf sich selbst bezieht,
wie sie sich mit dem Wort ich auf sich selbst bezieht,
also ist der Unterschied zwischen ihrer
Aussage oder ihrem Glauben, dass
Jones wohlhabend ist  und ich glaube, dass ich wohlhabend bin,
ist kein Unterschied darin, auf wen oder
was Bezug
genommen wird  Ich glaube, dass Jones
wohlhabend ist. Ich glaube, dass ich wohlhabend bin,
aber nicht das zweite. Ich glaube,
dass Jones
wohlhabend ist
weil sie denken, es ist einfach zu sagen
, dass du dich ausnutzt ja, wenn du glaubst, dass du
selbst reich bist, das ist nur der X-
Glaube, dass X reich ist, nein, der X
glaubt, dass X Reichtum ist  y
bringt X nur dazu zu glauben, dass X
unter einer bestimmten Beschreibung wohlhabend ist, nicht dass sie
selbst wohlhabend ist, also ist das in
Ordnung, es ist eine robuste Ich-Perspektive
froh, dass ich ein
Philosoph bin oder ich frage mich, wie
ich sterben werde, kein Name oder keine Beschreibung kann
das zweite Vorkommen von AI in
einem dieser Sätze ersetzen, ohne
seine Bedeutung zu ändern, wenn ich mich frage, wie
ich sterben werde, frage ich mich nicht  wie dann Baker
sterben wird oder wie die Person
, die dies schreibt, die wir hier vor
Ihnen stehen, sterben wird. Ich frage mich, wie
ich sterben werde, wo das Quadrat des
zweiten Auges ein Selbstkonzept ausdrückt, das ein
Selbstkonzept ausdrückt  nicht alleine zu stehen
, um ein Selbstkonzept zu erwerben, muss ein
Sprachenlerner eine Batterie
von empirischen Konzepten haben, wie z
und so weiter, und man könnte diese Wörter nur lernen,
wenn man sich in einem sozialen und
sprachlichen Umfeld befände. Unser soziales
Wesen ermöglicht es uns, natürliche Sprache zu lernen
und damit
Selbstkonzepte und eine Explosion weiterer
konzeptueller Fähigkeiten zu erwerben. Ich erwähnte dies, um zu
zeigen, wie weit  Ich bin von Descartes, wenn
Sie sagen, dass die Leute aus der Ich-Perspektive
sofort an Descartes denken, aber wie
weit bin ich von Descartes entfernt, der es für
selbstverständlich hielt, dass er, wenn er allein auf der
Welt wäre, abgesehen von einem bösen Dämon, der ihn
täuschte, ihn unterhalten müsste
Ich dachte, er säße
vor dem Feuer und ein böser Dämon
könnte ihn betrügen, das ist in der
ersten Meditation, da Sie
meiner Ansicht nach zweifellos genau wissen, ob Descartes
allein im Universum gewesen wäre, abgesehen von dem
bösen Dämon, er würde es nicht tun  Der
Beeinträchtigte habe die konzeptionellen Mittel gehabt zu
vermuten, er säße vor
dem Feuer
geschweige denn, dass er sich ohne
sprachabhängige
robuste Tannen täuschen lassen könnte  t-Person-Perspektive
Descartes hätte sich nicht über den
Gedanken täuschen können, dass ich
vor dem Feuer sitze, ohne dass
andere ihn lehren und korrigieren,
wie er sich überhaupt den
Begriff eines Feuers oder des Sitzens angeeignet hätte, so meine Vorstellung von einem
ersten  -Personen-Perspektive ist entschieden
nicht kartesisch, so dass wir eine glaubwürdige evolutionäre Geschichte darüber erzählen können, wie wir, wie wir die freundliche
Person geworden sind,
zu Menschen wurden. Es ist leicht zu erkennen,
wie Bewusstsein und Intentionalität die
Bestandteile einer rudimentären
Ich denke,
es ist sowieso einfach,
Mutationen, die beliebige
neuronale Muster erzeugen, die
Bewusstsein und zielgerichtetes Verhalten
ausmachen, hätten sicherlich die
Überlebenschancen von Tieren verbessert, die
Bewusstsein haben und sich
zielgerichtet verhalten  Wege haben mehr
Verhaltensflexibilität und sind daher
eher anpassungsfähig
als andere  äh, ansonsten ähnliche Tiere
, denen Bewusstsein und Intentionalität fehlt,
Art für Art,
Tiere mit höheren Ebenen des
Bewusstseins und feinkörniger
Intentionalität, haben wahrscheinlich einen
evolutionären Vorteil, also gab
es vielleicht eine Evolutionsperiode, in der
es Ma'am gab, Tiere mit
rudimentärem  Ego-Perspektiven,
aber keine robusten Ego-Perspektiven
Vielleicht gab es Hominiden, aber noch keine
Personen
Ich denke, dass es durchaus möglich ist, dass
es Organismen gab, die Hominiden waren
Hominiden, die keine robuste
Ego-Perspektive hatten, aber
rudimentäre Ego-Perspektiven hatten
Junge Hominiden hatten rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektiven, hatten aber
noch keine Fähigkeit zweiter Ordnung
, robuste Ich-Perspektiven zu entwickeln.
Damals gab es soziale Wesen in dieser Welt, aber sie waren noch keine
vollständig sprachlichen Wesen, als Gruppen von
Hominiden die Sprache erfanden und  Gehirne haben
sich bis zu dem Punkt entwickelt, an dem sie
unterstützen können  eine robuste Ich-
Perspektive eine neue Art von Wesen
entstand eine Person, vielleicht nicht
biologisch neu und aber ontologisch
neu oder Wesen mit neuen Arten von kausalen
Kräften, zum Beispiel kausalen Kräften
, komplizierte Syntax zu lernen und
komplexe Konventionen zu entwickeln, die
komplizierte Transaktionen wie regeln  Die
Übertragung von Eigentum Meine Vermutung ist,
dass der Erwerb von Sprache durch unsere
Spezies einen ontologischen Unterschied
in der Art von Wesen ausmachte, dass es Personen gibt, die
aus Tieren bestehen, die im
Wesentlichen Ich-Perspektiven haben
und die typischerweise robuste
Ich-Perspektiven erwerben, die wir menschlichen
Tiere haben  Personen sind
durch unsere Abstammung und
rudimentäre Ich-Perspektiven eine nette Verbindung zum Tierreich,
aber was uns einzigartig im Universum macht,
glaube ich, sind unsere robusten Ich
-Perspektiven unsere Fähigkeit,
uns selbst in der ersten Person
ohne Namen zu sehen oder  Beschreibung, also
entschuldigen Sie mich jetzt, wie Sie und ich einzelne
Personen geworden sind c  Der Institutionalismus ist
unter anderem ein Bericht darüber, wie
bestimmte Einheiten verschiedener Art entstehen.
Alles, was wir
wissen, was nach dem
Urknall entstand, entstand allmählich,
von Sonnensystemen über Organismen bis hin zu
Automobilen, die vom Fließband kamen, also
nehme ich an, dass Vagheit ist  Der Welt innewohnend,
so ist es auch bei Personen, dass es
keinen genauen Zeitpunkt gibt, an dem eine Person entsteht
, wenn ein später ausgetragener menschlicher Fötus
eine rudimentäre Ich-
Perspektive entwickelt, es
wird eine Person mit einer rudimentären
Ich-Perspektive  Perspektive oder hat einen Bruder
, der
in diesem Fall im Wesentlichen eine rudimentäre Ich-Perspektive und
auch eine Fähigkeit zweiter Ordnung hat,
eine robuste Ich-
Perspektive zu entwickeln
ermöglicht es dem
fötalen Organismus, der Person, die der Organismus zu konstituieren beginnt, sozusagen die
Ich-Perspektive zu übergeben
Es ist, als ob der konstituierende Organismus durch die Weitergabe
der rudimentären Ich-Perspektive
seine
ontologische Vormachtstellung an die Person sät, dass
er dazu kommt, die grundlegende
Einheit einer Person zu
konstituieren  Säugling ist eine Person, aber ein
Schimpanse ist keine Person,
obwohl die Person und der
Organismus biologisch ähnlich sind und beide
rudimentäre Ich-Perspektiven
haben, sind sie ontologisch verschieden. Der
Unterschied besteht darin, dass der menschliche Säugling, aber
nicht der Schimpanse im Wesentlichen eine
Fernbedienung hat  oder Fähigkeit zweiter Ordnung
, eine robuste Ich-
Perspektive zu entwickeln, lassen Sie mich
diese entfernte Fähigkeit, eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive zu entwickeln, näher erläutern. Ein normales
Kleinkind hat eine entfernte oder zweite
Fähigkeit, Fahrrad zu fahren
, die es entwickeln kann
Fähigkeit, Fahrrad
zu fahren Sobald sie Fahrrad fahren gelernt
hat, hat sie eine verbesserte Fähigkeit,
Fahrrad analog zu normalem zu fahren  Das menschliche
Kind hat eine entfernte Fähigkeit,
eine robuste Ich-Perspektive zu entwickeln, sobald
es eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive über ein Selbstkonzept entwickelt
hat, indem es eine natürliche Sprache lernt, hat es
eine verbesserte Fähigkeit, sich
selbst als sich selbst und die erste
Person zu begreifen  Eine robuste Ich-
Perspektive ist einzigartig für Personen,
ein Schimpanse oder ein anderer Organismus, der
keine Person darstellt, hat keine so
entfernte Fähigkeit, eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive zu entwickeln, so dass gemäß dem
Konstitutionalismus ein menschliches Kind, aber nicht
ein menschlicher Fötus, der dies nicht tut
eine Person darstellen, aber eine entfernte
Fähigkeit zur Entwicklung einer robusten
Ich-Perspektive haben, hat man keine
entfernte Fähigkeit, eine
Perspektive der Ich-Perspektive zu entwickeln,
bis sie eine rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektive in der Hand hat, aber auch eine
entfernte Fähigkeit hat, sich zu entwickeln  eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive sie sind von der
Art sie sind von der Art sie sind von der
Art die typischerweise das
erweiterte ca entwickelt  Sie sind wir sind Ich
hätte sagen sollen, dass wir von einer Art sind, die
typischerweise die erhöhte Fähigkeit
für eine robuste Ich-Perspektive entwickelt,
wenn wir eine Sprache lernen -
um an dieser Stelle den Unterschied
zwischen einem menschlichen Säugling zusammenzufassen, der  ist eine Person
in einem Schimpansen, die keine Person ist,
dass das menschliche Kind die Person von einer
Art ist, deren Mitglieder typischerweise die
Fähigkeit haben, sich selbst als sich
selbst in der ersten Person zu begreifen
Schimpansen sind keine Mitglieder einer solchen
Art, was mich jetzt ausmacht  Ich, wir sind alle
Personen in diesem Raum, es gibt viele
Personen in diesem Raum, aber eine bin ich und
eine ist Antonia, eine bist du, was
mich zu dieser Person macht, ist, dass ich dieses
Beispiel einer Ich-Perspektive bin
, das ist jetzt nicht informativ
Wortschatz Ich habe es nur gegeben, Sohn Informant Nicht
informativ, aber ich denke, es ist der
Preis für die Nichtreduzierung von Informativ Informativ zu
sein erfordert nicht persönliche
Bedingungen nicht persönliche Bedingungen für
Personen, wenn Sie nicht persönliche
Bedingungen hatten  ungen, die notwendig sind,
reicht für Personen aus, dann hätten Sie
eine Reduzierung von Personen auf diese
Bedingungen, die wir nicht wollen.
Ich möchte keine Reduzierung. Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das reduzieren können
macht dies
zu dieser Zeit dieselbe Person wie diese später zu
dieser Zeit, also was macht Sie zu derselben
Person, die Sie 2010 vor
vielleicht zehn Jahren vor einigen Jahren waren,
was macht Sie zur selben Person,
was Sie zur selben Person macht?  dass
Sie dasselbe Beispiel einer Ich-
Perspektive sind, aber das heißt nur, dass
Sie dieselbe Person sind, die nicht
informativ ist, aber wie gesagt, ich denke, dass
Nicht-Informiertheit der Preis ist, den man
für Nicht-Reduktion zahlen muss, und ich selbst denke nicht
Reduktion ist diesen Platz wert, also warum
macht eine robuste Ich-
Perspektive überhaupt einen ontologischen Unterschied,
warum sagen wir nicht einfach, dass Personen
mit Tieren identisch sind, die diese
besondere Eigenschaft haben, nämlich die Fähigkeit
, eine erste Person zu entwickeln?  rson-Perspektive Nun, zunächst
gibt es mindestens zwei Gründe,
obwohl ich die Biologie gerne den Biologen überlasse, ist
mein Bericht ontologisch
und ich sehe keinen Grund anzunehmen, dass die
Ontologie die Biologie rekapitulieren sollte, die
robuste Ich-Perspektive ist
entscheidend, wie ich veranschaulichen werde  in einem Moment
der Zivilisation, aber Biologen nicht so
wichtig erscheint, ist eines meiner
Ziele, das Tierreich als
nahtlos ohne scharfe Brüche zu betrachten, um anzunehmen,
dass bestimmte Tiere menschliche Tiere
ein einzigartiges Merkmal haben, das für Biologen unwichtig,
aber für uns entscheidend ist und  Entscheidend
für charakteristische menschliche Aktivitäten scheint
nicht nur eine Spaltung im
Tierreich zu sein, sondern auch eine Spaltung
auf eine von Biologen nicht genehmigte Weise. Zweitens,
was etwas
grundsätzlich zu der Art von Ding macht, das es
ist, ist nicht immer das, woraus es
besteht  nur ein physikalischer fehler
woraus dein pass gemacht ist,
ist irrelevant, ob es sich um einen pass handelt
was dein 20-euro-schein ist
ist irrelevant,
weil es ein 20-Euro-Büro ist, es ist nicht völlig irrelevant, weil
es etwas gesetzlich Sanktioniertes
sein muss, aber sie könnten ändern,
sie könnten ändern, Sie könnten ändern, sie könnten
die Zusammensetzung des 20-Euro-
Scheins ändern, und dann Sie  Weißt du, du hast es.
Ich bin sicher, es tut mir leid. Ich weiß nicht viel
über Euro-Scheine. Okay, es macht Spaß.
Was dieses Etwas grundsätzlich zu dem macht,
was es ist, ist nicht immer das,
woraus es zum Beispiel organisches
Material besteht, aber
Was etwas zu einer Uhr macht, ist eher, dass es dazu
bestimmt ist, die Zeit anzuzeigen, egal aus was
es besteht. Uhren können auf
Millionen von verschiedenen Arten hergestellt werden
rudimentäre rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektive und eine entfernte
Fähigkeit, eine robuste
Ich-Perspektive zu entwickeln, ist diese
Fähigkeit eine nicht qualitative Dispositionseigenschaft,
die sua großzügig ist und
nicht auf ein Drittes reduziert werden kann
Die robuste Ich-
Perspektive des persönlichen Eigentums bringt eine Vielzahl neuer
Arten von kausalen Kräften mit
ausreichend signifikanten Unterschieden mit sich, von denen ich glaube, dass sie
die ontologische Einzigartigkeit von Personen unterstützen.
Lassen Sie mich diesen Punkt gut veranschaulichen. Beide
Ich-Perspektiven sind
an vielen der Merkmale beteiligt  Aktivitäten
von Personen Aktivitäten, aufgrund derer
sie Verträge abschließen
Jubiläen feiern den Ehrgeiz haben,
Miss America zu werden, es sei denn, sie sind zu
alt, um Philanthropen zu werden, die wollen, dass
neue Gebäude nach ihnen benannt werden, um
Tagebücher zu führen usw. Wir könnten nicht einmal
viele davon haben  Gedanken, die wir haben,
ohne robuste Ich-
Perspektiven zu haben, selbst triviale Gedanken wie
Ich wünschte, ich wäre ein Filmstar, sind direkte
Manifestationen einer robusten Ich-
Perspektive. Niemand könnte einen solchen
Gedanken haben, es sei denn, Sie könnten
sich von Anfang an als sie selbst begreifen  -Person
Lassen Sie mich nur
einige unserer kausalen Kräfte auflisten, die
die von Tieren übertreffen, die dies nicht tun  stellen
Personen einen Gegenstand dar, den wir mit mehreren Arten teilen,
die Fähigkeit, mit Artgenossen zu kommunizieren,
aber nur wir Personen haben eine
vollständig artikulierte Sprache mit
Ressourcen, um Notwendigkeit und Möglichkeit zu berücksichtigen
eine Perspektive auf unsere
Umwelt, aber nur wir Menschen sind
reich und ihr Leben voller
Kontrafaktualien, wenn ich nur die
Tür abgeschlossen hätte. Dieser Gegenstand, den wir mit mehreren Arten teilen.
Methoden der rationalen Untersuchung
aber nur wir Personen überlegen,
was zu tun ist, und versuchen, unsere
Vorlieben und Ziele einzuordnen und
Konflikte zwischen ihnen zu lösen und somit
rationale Agenten zu sein
teilen
mit mehreren Arten die Fähigkeit,
Dinge herzustellen, die wir zum Beispiel brauchen  Die Nester,
aber nur Reaper-Syns machen Dinge, die
wir nicht brauchen, zum Beispiel genug
Atomsprengköpfe, um die menschliche Rasse um ein Vielfaches zu eliminieren.
Artikel, den wir mit
mehreren Arten teilen, die Eigenschaft, eine
soziale Organisation zu haben, aber nur Personen
, die Kriegsverbrechen begehen, werden von internationalen
Gerichten anerkannt und anerkannt  Menschenrechtsgegenstand
Wir teilen mit anderen Spezies die
Eigenschaft, eine rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektive zu haben, aber nur wir
Personen können moralische oder verantwortliche
Akteure sein. All diese Unterschiede zwischen
Personen und anderen Wesen beruhen darauf, dass wir
robuste Ich-Perspektiven haben  Sie
bringen eine Kaskade neuer Arten von
Fähigkeiten mit sich Wir können unsere Zukunft planen Wir
können uns selbst betrügen
Wir können versuchen uns zu reformieren Wir können Diäten machen
Wir können reich oder leer in unserem Leben sein
und so weiter und so weiter in Bezug auf die
Bandbreite von beidem  was wir tun können, von dem Versuch,
unser Schicksal zu kontrollieren, bis hin zu Fantasien
über die Zukunft und in Bezug auf die
moralische Bedeutung dessen, was wir können
Von der Beurteilung unserer Ziele bis zum Bekennen
unserer Sünden ist es offensichtlich, dass Wesen mit
robuster Ich-Perspektive
einzigartig sind. Das Ausmaß des Unterschieds,
den die robuste Ich-Perspektive
ausmacht, ist ein Zeichen dafür, dass wir Menschen uns
ontologisch von Tieren unterscheiden, lassen Sie
mich zusammenfassen  Indem wir wiederholen, dass der
wichtige Unterschied zwischen einer menschlichen
Person und einem menschlichen Tier und
einem Menschen oder einer Person kein
biologischer Unterschied, sondern ein ontologischer
Unterschied ist, erkennen Sie jetzt, dass
Ontologie nicht jedermanns Sache ist, wie auch
immer sie es ist  Im Wesentlichen eine Ich-
Perspektive zu haben, die zeigt, wie
wir materielle Objekte sein können, ohne im
Wesentlichen Tiere zu sein, entschuldigen Sie, wenn wir
materielle Objekte sind, die im
Wesentlichen keine Tiere sind, müssen wir sowohl den
Materialismus als auch den
Tierismus ablehnen
sich nicht an immaterielle
Wesenheiten wie Seelen wendend,
vermeidet der Konstitutionalismus Animalismus durch ta  organische
Körper als wesentlich für uns zu betrachten und
die Veränderungen zu erkennen, die durch die Biotechnologie gemäß dem Konstitutionalismus bewirkt werden,
solange ein Körper die Perspektive der ersten Person unterstützt
, stellt er eine Person dar,
egal wie viele anorganische Teile er hat,
was uns mit dem Tier verbindet  Königreich ist,
dass wir zu Beginn unserer Existenz aus
menschlichen Organismen bestehen, die rudimentäre
Ich-Perspektiven unterstützen, und was
uns von allen anderen Wesen unterscheidet, ist, dass
wir
in einigen
Konstitutionalismus-Beats in der Regel robuste Personenperspektiven entwickeln, die
beide eingangs genannten Ziele erfüllen
beides bindet uns an das Tierreich und
es zeigt, dass wir einzigartig sind.
Schlussendlich Schlussendlich biete ich den
Konstitutionalismus als meine Theorie der
natürlichen Personen an und ich konstruiere das, was
ich Personen durch Konventionseinheiten nenne,
wie juristische Personen in Ramat dramatis
personae als ein ontologisches II  abhängig
von natürlichen Personen meine
Konstitution Personenlehre erklärt die
linguis  tische Asymmetrie in der Verwendung des
Wortes Person im Sinne einer ontologischen
Asymmetrie nach meiner Theorie, wenn eine
neue natürliche Person entsteht, entsteht
eine neue Entität, wenn
Person im verankernden Sinn verwendet wird,
wie das Wort Person im verankernden Sinn verwendet wird
Verankerungssinn Personen haben ontologische
Bedeutung Zu sagen, dass Personen
ontologische Bedeutung haben, bedeutet zu sagen, dass
jedes Inventar konkreter Objekte, denen
Personen fehlen, unvollständig ist, aber
eine der Personen durch Konvention
entsteht Personen durch Konvention
entsteht Person wird nicht
verwendet  Verankerungssinn keine neue Entität
entsteht eine Figur in einem
Stück keine neue Entität ist ontologischer II-
Sicht eher eine Rolle, die eine
bereits existierende natürliche Person spielen kann
eine Gesellschaft ist keine neue Entität, wenn ein
Gericht sie für eine Person hält
neue Eigenschaften erwirbt, haben die Personen
konventionell keine ontologische
Bedeutung, da sie Personen
natürliche Person sind  ns wie wir haben eine
ontologische Bedeutung
, da wir Personen sind, also landen wir mit einer Zählung
innerhalb eines Berichts darüber, was endliche Personen
sind und wie sie existieren, danke
[Applaus]